quelle je m'efforcerai de répondre lors
de la discussion des articles le texte
qui vous est soumis en force les
instruments du pilotage du nouveau
modèle énergétique dont dispose l'état
en plafonnant à son niveau actuel notre
capacité de production nucléaire et en
instaurant pour tout exploitant
produisant plus du tiers de la
production électrique nationale un plan
stratégique précisant les actions qu'ils
s'engagent à mettre en oeuvre pour
respecter les objectifs de
diversification de la production
électrique inscrit dans notre
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
dont vous allez maîtriser la montée en
charge
si le niveau et le rip du plafonnement
ne font pas encore consensus entre nous
sans principe n'est toutefois pas mis en
cause et donc je pense que nous avons là
une bonne base pour discuter et pourrait
changer
plusieurs articles renforce le rôle des
territoires dans la transition
énergétique reconnaisse un droit à
l'expérimentation de boucle locale
fédérant les producteurs et les
consommateurs dans le cadre d'une
production décentralisée de l'énergie
ainsi que la possibilité d'un
déploiement expérimental de réseaux
électriques intelligents dans une
perspective de développement de l'auto
consommation ou de construction de
villes ou de quartiers intelligent avec
tous les savoir-faire que la france doit
pouvoir développer ce titre prévoit
également la création d'un chèque
énergie traitant équitablement
l'ensemble des énergies pour lutter
contre la précarité énergétique
je salue d'ailleurs les améliorations
apportées par votre commission des
affaires économiques à ce dispositif qui
est très attendu enfin le projet de loi
reconnaît pleinement la spécificité et
le potentiel d outre mer les difficultés
résultant de la non l'interconnexion
nous pousse à innover et peuvent se
transformer en avantages pour que les
territoires ultramarins deviennent
l'avant-garde de la transition
énergétique et met le cap sur une
autonomie
énergétique fondée sur leurs propres
ressources renouvelables dans ces
territoires le chômage frappe durement
jusqu'à des taux de 40% voire 50% des
jeunes
il est évident que ces nouvelles
filières constituent des atouts
considérables de création d'activités et
d'emplois non délocalisables
et dans cette perspective il ne s'agit
plus pour nos autres maires de rattraper
un modèle à bout de souffle mais au
contraire d'anticiper et même de
devancer grâce à la valorisation de
leurs atouts le changement de modèle
dont la croissance verte doit être le
moteur dans tout le pays
j'en viens au moyen que le gouvernement
entend consacrer à ses priorités on me
dit parfois que la transition
énergétique coûterait trop cher
je crois qu'il dans ce domaine c'est
l'inaction qui serait qui coûterait très
cher
souvenons nous par exemple en ce qui
concerne le dérèglement climatique des
inondations dans notre pays et même des
victimes nombreuses sur les territoires
de nos régions et même de ma région
poitou charentes pays de voir qu'ils ont
durement frappé ce tribut aux
dérèglements climatiques et dans le
monde entier d'ailleurs les acteurs
économiques commencent en prendre
pleinement conscience
en septembre dernier au sommet mondial
de l'onu à new york
j'ai été frappé de voir avec quelle
énergie si j'ose dire des pans entiers
du monde industriel et des affaires
américain s'engage désormais de tout
leur poids dans l'économie verte et nous
ne pouvons pas être en retard sur ce
mouvement ils ont fait leurs comptes ils
ont compris que l'inaction a et aura un
coût infiniment supérieur à celui de la
transition énergétique car le
dérèglement climatique et la
multiplication des événements
météorologiques extrêmes menacent les
infrastructures côtières organise des
pertes considérables et les acteurs
économiques sont de plus en plus
nombreux à comprendre que la croissance
verte qui réconcilie l'économie et
l'écologie devient un gisement
d'innovation technologique et de
production de richesses le cinquième
rapport du giec
explique que sur la nouvelle économie
climatique ainsi que le rapport stern
calderon de l'ancien président mexicain
disent la même chose
j'entends aussi parfois que les moyens
ne serait pas au rendez vous et bien si
les moyens sont là à nous de nous en
saisir pour les particuliers le
gouvernement a créé vous l'avez voté la
création d'un crédit d'impôt pour la
transition énergétique simplifiée
renforcée et élargie dans la loi de
finances pour 2015 qui permet de
financer jusqu'à 30% du montant des
travaux d'isolation la simplification et
le déblocage de l'éco prêt à taux zéro
qui pourra bénéficier à 100 mille
opérations de rénovation en pour cette
année le financement de l'anah de l'
agence nationale pour l'amélioration de
l'habitat a été complété la mise en
place pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas faire
la vence du financement des travaux du
tiers financement partir du vote de
cette loi et de l'expérience des régions
pionnières va permettre aux particuliers
d'engager leurs travaux pour les
entreprises la banque publique
d'investissement assumera pleinement ses
responsabilités de banques de la
transition énergétique notamment avec
les prêts verts aux entreprises qui ont
des projets de réduction de leur
consommation d'énergie pour les
collectivités territoriales les prêts
transition énergétique et croissance
verte de la caisse des dépôts sont
disponibles depuis le 1er août avec une
enveloppe de 5 milliards d'euros pour
des prêts à un taux de 1 75% sans apport
initial est remboursable en 40 ans la
banque européenne d'investissement dont
j'ai pu apprécier l'efficacité comme
partenaires des projets de la région
poitou charentes mobilise également un
milliard d'euros pour les travaux de
rénovation énergétique dans les collèges
en soutien des départements enfin le
fonds de financement de la transition
énergétique est aujourd'hui opérationnel
logé à la caisse des dépôts et
consignations il est doté d'un milliard
et demi d'euros sur trois ans issus des
certificats d'économie d'énergie du
programme des investissements d'avenir
et des dividendes du secteur de
l'énergie
ce fonds financera directement dans les
territoires les actions des lauréats les
appels à projets
et donc permettra l'engagement rapide
des travaux qui doivent bénéficier à la
filière bâtiment aux entreprises et aux
bâtiments et aux entreprises et aux
artisans de cette filière qui attendent
avec impatience des bénéficier des
marchés publics concernant les travaux
sur les bâtiments publics les bâtiments
privés les logements sociaux et les
logements des particuliers
les moyens existent donc certains sont
déjà mises en place et c'était très
important qu'il soit stabilisée au
moment où votre assemblée à débattre de
cette loi ce projet de loi est également
je tiens à le souligner est
l'aboutissement d'un dialogue renforcé
avec bien évidemment les élus que vous
êtes mais aussi les associations les
scientifiques les entrepreneurs les
artisans des filières de la croissance
verte
les membres des organismes consultatifs
en particulier le conseil économique
social et environnemental qui en a été
saisi le conseil national de la
transition écologique qui en a débattu
je souhaite que vos travaux et que les
propositions de vos rapporteurs avec
lesquels nous avons noué de fructueuses
relations de travail au cours des
dernières semaines
c'est vrai permettent d'améliorer encore
ce texte est de lui donner toute sa
portée opérationnelle pour accélérer
pour approfondir cette mobilisation qui
est déjà enclenché concrètement au cours
de ces mois de travail intense dont j'ai
eu la responsabilité
j'ai veillé à prendre en compte nombre
de recommandations de toutes les parties
prenantes de la transition énergétique
j'ai tenu à être à l'écouté et je
continuerai à l'être au cours de vos
débats pour comprendre tous les points
de vue attentive à ce qui permet de les
rapprocher dans le respect des
convictions de chacun sans gommer bien
évidemment artificiellement les
différences d'approché mais avec le
souci de trouver des points de
convergence déséquilibre positif au
service de tous les français
tel est l'état d'esprit qui a présidé à
l'élaboration de ce texte et dans lequel
j'aborde ce débat au sénat
je sais que cet état d'esprit
et partagés par vos commissions dont je
tiens à saluer la mobilisation
exceptionnelle 127 auditions ont été
conduites par votre commission des
affaires économiques ou son rapporteur
et qui ont indiqué leur intention de
conforter le projet de loi cinquante
cinq heures de réunion ils ont été
consacrés par votre commission du
développement durable qui a vu dans ce
texte un grenelle 3 un projet global à
aborder je cite avec pragmatisme et sans
idéologie
j'y vois pour ma part une attitude
particulièrement constructive qui place
le débat sous d'excellents auspices
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
projet de loi que je vous propose
n'accumule pas des contraintes
supplémentaires
il met à la portée de chaque acteur de
la croissance verte des moyens concrets
de s'impliquer
il incarne une écologie positive qui
lève des freins libère des initiatives
et des liberté d'entreprendre pour
apporter dès aujourd'hui des bénéfices
concrets notamment en termes d'emploi ce
projet de loi ne pose pas les énergies
les unes aux autres
ils organisent leur complémentarité dans
la perspective d'un nouveau modèle
énergétique évolutif plus diversifiée
c'est un texte d'équilibré qui vise à
permettre à la france de tirer le
meilleur parti des nombreux atouts qui
sont les siens les a tout d'abord que
notre histoire nous a légué et qui
sécurise notre transition énergétique
les atouts qui nous permette de devenir
une puissance environnementales de
premier plan grâce à ces énergies
renouvelables très diverses dont dispose
notre pays y compris nos outre-mer le
deuxième domaine maritime mondial
la france a le deuxième domaine maritime
mondial le premier potentiel agricole de
l'importance de la biomasse que vous
avez d'ailleurs renforcé au cours de vos
travaux et le troisième potentiel
forestier européen grâce ensuite à
l'excellence de nos chercheurs de nos
ingénieurs au talent et au savoir faire
de grands groupes mais aussi de nos pme
et de nos articles
en grâce à la capacité d'initiative l
envie de participer des citoyens à la
motivation à l'engagement des élus de
nos territoires
au delà des clivages politiques comme je
le constate et encore hier je le répète
en félicitant les lauréats de ces
territoires à énergie positive ne
débattons aujourd'hui du projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique
nous débattrons bientôt du projet de loi
sur la biodiversité
ils sont l'un et l'autre complémentaires
car leurs enjeux sont intimement liés on
le sait le dérèglement climatique
aggrave l'érosion de la biodiversité
fragilise des écosystèmes qui nous
rendent pourtant des services vitaux les
espèces végétales et animales
n'ayant plus le temps de s'adapter en 40
ans 52 des espèces vertébrées ont
disparu de la planète menace les forêts
les maires les récifs coralliens les
terres qui nous nourrissent l'eau sans
laquelle il n'est pas de vie possible et
pour laquelle déjà bien des conflits se
dessine mais de cela peut sortir aussi
le meilleur car une biodiversité
intelligemment préserver et valoriser
limite les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et de pollution atténue la dérive
climatique protège mieux de ce compte de
ses conséquences
c'est vrai entre autres des forêts
côtières des mangroves qui ralentit ce
déferlement des inondations c'est vrai
de l'apport de l'agro écologie et du
génie écologique ou du retour de la
nature en ville ou par exemple l'effet
des arbres protège des canicules urbaine
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
premier sommet de la terre proclamé en
1972 tout être humain à deux patries la
sienne et la planète
le projet de loi qui vous est présentée
doit nous permettre de prendre
efficacement soin de l'une et de l'autre
de donner aux français l'espoir et les
moyens de vivre mieux en créant les
emplois qui vont avec
dans un pays qui reprend son destin
énergétique
main et plus largement peut à nouveau
inventer son avenir dans les territoires
dont vous êtes les élus vous le voyez
bien parce que vous êtes actif et vous
vous engager la transition énergétique
est en marche
il nous faut donc consolider généralisée
approfondir cette dynamique
tel est l'objectif de ce débat qui nous
rassemble avec à la clé je le répète la
possibilité de créer des emplois comme
le bon cognac du poitou charentes qui
doit passer deux fois par l'alambic
avant d'entamer la lente maturation que
lui conférera son arôme définitif la
lecture donc la deuxième après
l'assemblée nationale au sénat de ce
texte que nous entamons aujourd'hui va
permettre je l'espère de donner à notre
pays le ti législatif mûrement réfléchie
soigneusement élaborées dont il a besoin
pour réussir pleinement sa transition
énergétique et faire de la croissance
verte
notre commune nouvelle frontière je vous
remercie
voilà vous êtes donc pu suivre la
discussion générale sur le projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique tout de
suite michel grossiord reçoit frédéric
péchenard dans preuve par trois